Now I'm not actually personally a hardcore singularitarian. Which may surprise some of you.
But I've always been very intrigued by the concept.
And I took it on as a sort of a challenge to see
if I could write a meaningful fictional story
that would be set after the Singularity.
And that led to these books:
starting with the Quantum Thief and it's sequels.
As I was writing them I became aware of
this Russian thinker Nikolai Fedorov
who'd anticipated ideas that sounded very much like the modern idea of the Singularity back in the 1890s.
In the Quantum Thief books that was a little side note.
But after finishing the books I kind of was intrigued by it.
I started wondering whether there had been times in the past when it felt like the Singularity was coming.
and what did it feel like to live in those times?
And it turned out that this was very much the case.
The result was my recent novel Summerland
which just came out.
It is a spy story set in an alternate world where
a very different kind of singularity has taken place.
Scientists have proven that the afterlife is real
and can be contacted by a radio.
It was inspired by real-life Victorian spiritualists;
ideas from four dimensional geometry;
and etheric physics.
And today I want to tell you more
about all those crazy ideas
and tell you some stories from real history.
And maybe we can discuss all together what those stories can teach us about our present-day worries
and hopes about the Singularity.
So to start let's go back in time 180 years
to 1838 and the invention of the electric telegraph.
180 years ago Samuel Morse sent
the first telegram in the United States;
that was across just two miles of telegraph wire.
But the telegraph exploded at an exponential rate
and just ten years later there was 6,000 miles
of telegraph cable in the United States.
6,000 miles in just 10 years.
Tom Standage has called the telegraph network,
"The Victorian Internet."
I think that's a very good parallel.
There was this explosion of growth.
Wild West period of sort of different competing technologies and different companies.
And ultimately a consolidation when
the Western Telegraph Union was formed.
It became sort of a Google of its time.
And by the year 1900 it controlled
a million miles of telegraph lines.
Now very to the Rochester NY headquarters
of Western Union,
was a small town called Hyattsville.
On March 31, 1848 something quite strange
happened there. These two sisters,
Kate and Margaret Fox, started
receiving messages from the afterlife.
The messages came as rapping noises that had a code.
So multiple raps for no; one rap for yes...
So similar to the Morse code in the telegraph.
Initially the girls told their family that the messages came from this creature called Mr. Split Foot.
Maybe the devil. But later changed their story and said
it was the spirit of a peddler who had
been murdered in their home.
It happened that the Fox family was friends
with an influential, radical Quaker family
that lived in Rochester. And they got very excited about the possibility of directly communicating with the dead.
And they formed what became
the core of the Spiritualist movement.
And suddenly there was this explosion of mediums.
The Fox sisters got hundreds of imitators.
They themselves became very famous.
Horace Greeley the newspaper man and politician
took them under his wing.
The timing was right for something like this.
The US was going through what is now known as the Second Great Awakening.
That was kind of a Protestant religious revival that emphasized a personal relationship with God.
It came with a fascination with
the supernatural and romanticism.
So people got very excited when suddenly there was what you could describe as an open source religion.
That promised direct lines of communication
with the dead.
Because the early spiritualists were associated with groups like Quakers and Universalists,
they were also very much into social reforms, abolition of slavery, women's rights, and so on.
Mediums were mostly women, so that gave women a new kind of voice that helped drive some of their issues.
But when I looked into this, what surprised me was
how closely the language used to describe mediums was associated with telegraphy.
Here's a period drawing that describes a spiritual telegraph crossing the Atlantic.
Some mediums started using
telegraph transmission hardware.
First they used existing telegraph hardware
to channel spirits.
And then they started building
their own hardware for contacting spirits.
Here's an example of an alphabet wheel for communicating with the dead.
But it's actually modeled after a contemporary design,
one of the early alphabet wheels that made it easier
for a telegraph operator to read incoming messages.
So there's this interesting feedback loop between
the hardware that the mediums used
and the hardware that telegraph operators used.